yesterday morning children were sent
screaming in Terror
and residents scrambled into underground
shelters as a barrage of Russian
missiles bore down on the capital
President Vladimir zielinski hailed the
success of the us-made Patriot air
defense system
when Patriots are in Ukrainian hands he
said there is a 100
interception rate of any Russian missile
but as each side in this conflict tries
to gain the upper hand ahead of a
looming counter-offensive even Moscow is
starting to feel the Direct effects of
this war
according to Russian media more than 10
drones targeted the capital today
with around 300 people evacuated from a
high-rise building after it was damaged
in the attack